So imagine you're at this really crowded party.
You know, the music is a little too loud,
people are laughing, there's glasses clinking everywhere.
And you look across the room
and you notice three different people.
And all of them are standing completely alone,
just keeping their distance from the crowd.
On the surface, if you were just looking
at a snapshot of this, you would say
they are doing the exact same thing.
Yeah, the observable behavior is, well, it's identical.
I mean, they are physically isolating themselves
and keeping people at arm's length.
But the foundational principle of psychology
tells us that identical behaviors frequently mask
profoundly different internal motivations.
So two people can be standing alone at a party,
but, you know, one is terrified
and the other is just perfectly at peace.
Which brings us to the mission for today's deep dive.
Yeah.
We've got a stack of clinical diagnostic manuals here,
specifically the ICD 10 and 11
alongside some treatment literature
and psychological case studies.
Some really dense reading, yeah.
Exactly.
And we are unpacking a specific group
of psychological profiles known as
the cluster A personality disorders.
Right, which are clinically grouped
as the odd and eccentric personalities.
Yes, odd and eccentric.
And our goal for you, the listener,
is to understand the core mystery of that party scenario.
We wanna look past the physical distance
and figure out the mechanical why behind the isolation.
Because understanding that why
is the ultimate separator.
I mean, if you just catalog the behavior,
you completely miss the structural architecture
of the mind that's actually producing it.
Okay, let's unpack this.
We'll start with the first person standing alone
at that party.
This is paranoid personality disorder.
Officially coded in the diagnostic manual as F60.0.
Right, F60.0.
And the distance here is manufactured by fear and mistrust.
In reading through the case studies,
the best way I can conceptualize this is,
it's like walking through your entire life
wearing a massive, heavy, medieval suit of armor.
That's a really good way to put it.
You wear it to the grocery store,
you wear it to work, you wear it to sleep.
And yeah, it keeps you safe from incoming arrows,
but it makes it physically impossible to hug anyone.
But you know, that armor isn't empty.
Inside that heavy suit is a hyper-vigilant nervous system
that just never, ever powers down.
Never.
The diagnostic criteria actually specify
a pervasive, distressed, and suspiciousness of others.
And pervasive is the key word there.
Meaning it colors literally every interaction.
Exactly.
This is a baseline neurological assumption
that the world and everyone in it
is actively operating with hidden motives
to exploit, harm, or deceive them.
And the literature really emphasizes
how they read hidden threats
into just the most ordinary remarks.
Like if I walk up to this person at the party
and say, hey, nice shirt.
They aren't processing that as a compliment.
No, not at all.
Their internal radar just immediately scans
that benign comment for the threat.
They're thinking, why is he focusing on my clothes?
Is he mocking my weight?
Is it some kind of set up for a joke at my expense?
Wow.
And because that threat matrix is constantly running,
they hold these incredibly deep grudges
and they refuse to confine in anyone
because information is simply ammunition.
Right, any personal preference, any vulnerability,
any secret you share is immediately cataloged
by their brain as a weapon handed to the enemy.
Which sounds exhausting.
It is.
It's an incredibly rigid psychological posture.
Which brings up a glaring paradox
in the clinical treatment literature that I saw.
The manuals list psychotherapy as the first line treatment.
They do.
But engaging the patient seems mechanically impossible.
I mean, therapy requires sitting in a room,
making yourself vulnerable to a stranger,
and building a therapeutic alliance.
You're asking someone to take off their armor
in front of a clinician
when their brain is screaming
that the clinician is holding a sword.
Yeah, that is the ultimate clinical irony.
So how does a professional even bypass that defense system?
Well, you don't try to disarm them.
I mean, trying to force emotional vulnerability
or demanding trust from a patient with F60.0
will just instantly rupture the relationship.
So what do you do?
Instead, clinicians utilize this mechanism
of radical, almost clinical transparency.
They focus entirely on practical, somatic,
or external life stressors.
So if the patient is stressed about a landlord,
the therapist focuses on the landlord.
Okay, keeping it external.
Right.
Furthermore, the therapist externalizes their own process.
They might say, I'm gonna take notes now.
I am writing down what you said about your job
so I don't forget.
Oh, wow.
So you literally narrate what you're doing.
Exactly, you eliminate shadows.
Over a very long timeline,
the therapist kind of becomes a neutral fixture
in the patient's environment rather than a threat.
It's essentially treating the relationship
like a highly formalized contract
rather than an emotional bond.
That's exactly it.
But navigating that requires strict clinical boundaries,
especially regarding the diagnostic traps
mentioned in our sources.
The literature draws a very hard line
between paranoid personality disorder
and actual delusional disorders,
or, you know, poderomal schizophrenia.
We aren't talking about fixed, bizarre delusions here.
No, the boundary is reality testing.
Paranoid personality is an ingrained lifelong pattern
of viewing the world
through a deeply cynical, mistrustful lens.
But the patient is not experiencing frank psychosis.
They aren't hallucinating voices
commanding them to isolate.
If they interpret your comment
about their shirt as an insult,
that is a distortion of intent.
But if they genuinely believe the shirt is woven
with microchips transmitting their thoughts to the CIA,
well, the suspicion has hardened into a fixed delusion.
At that point, you have officially crossed the border
out of personality disorders entirely.
So the person in the armor at the party
knows it's a party.
They know you are just a person holding a cup of punch.
They just assume you're gonna throw the punch
in their face the second they look away.
Precisely.
It is a severe misinterpretation of social data,
not a hallucination of data that just isn't there.
Okay, so if the first person is trapped
inside a fortress of their own making, out of fear,
let's look at a mind that doesn't even want the fortress,
the kingdom, or the people in it.
The second person at the party.
Right, the second person standing along.
This represents schizoid personality disorder,
code F60BOLT11.
And the distance here is driven
by sheer unadulterated indifference.
Indifference is the perfect word.
It really is.
This profile pushes hard against the assumption
that human beings are universally driven
by a need for connection.
It's like someone who genuinely lacks
the taste receptors for chocolate,
living in a world that assumes absolutely
everyone has a sweet tooth.
Right, and society relentlessly offers them chocolate
and then pathologizes their refusal.
Exactly.
The defining mechanism of schizoid personality disorder
is profound social detachment paired
with a restricted emotional effect.
I mean, they are indifferent to praise,
immune to criticism, and experience zero distress
regarding their isolation.
That's wild to me.
Well, the social anhedonia is egosyntonic,
meaning it aligns entirely with their own self-image
and desires, they don't feel broken.
See, I have to challenge the idea
of complete indifference here,
just looking at this from an evolutionary biology perspective.
Humans are biologically wired as pack animals, right?
Our nervous systems regulate through connection
because, historically, isolation
literally meant death by predation.
So is it truly possible that a schizoid individual
has absolutely zero biological appetite for connection?
Or is the literature suggesting it's just suppressed
beneath some impenetrable dissociative layer?
It's a great question, but the clinical consensus
leans toward a structural neurodevelopmental deficit
in the actual social reward circuitry.
Really? Yeah.
When you or I have a positive social interaction,
our brains release this cascade of oxytocin and dopamine.
We feel warmth.
The schizoid brain just does not produce
or receive that same chemical reward.
Oh, wow, so the hardware is different.
Exactly.
The hardware processing social connection
simply doesn't fire the same way.
It isn't that they are actively suppressing
a desperate need for a hug,
it's that the hug registers as entirely neutral
or even just physically intrusive
without any emotional resonance.
Here's where it gets really interesting
in the diagnostic literature.
The sources highlight a major trap here,
which is confusing schizoid personality disorder
with avoidant personality disorder,
which sits over in cluster C.
Right, very common mix-up.
Because if you only look at the behavior,
both individuals are sitting alone in their apartments
on a Friday night, seemingly doing the exact same thing.
Right, but the distinction comes down
to the presence or absence of an internal drive.
Desire, essentially.
Yes, the schizoid person genuinely lacks
the appetite for connection.
They are reading a book,
perfectly at baseline, completely content.
The avoidant person, on the other hand,
is starving for connection.
But they're still alone.
Yes, they're sitting on their couch,
intensely tracking the party they weren't invited to,
paralyzed by a hypersensitivity to rejection
and this deep-seated belief in their own social inadequacy.
So never confuse, prefers to be alone
with afraid to be with people.
Exactly.
One is a lack of appetite,
the other is starvation caused by fear.
Knowing that, how does a clinician approach treatment
for F60.1?
Yeah.
I mean, if the patient has no desire
to change their social isolation
and they don't feel the stress about it,
what is the mechanical goal of supportive psychotherapy?
You can't really spark a flame
if there's no combustible material.
You can't.
So the goal shifts entirely away
from generating emotional intimacy
and moves toward functional adaptation.
Just getting by in the world.
Pretty much.
The modern world demands social interaction for survival.
You have to interview for jobs,
navigate corporate hierarchies,
interact with landlords.
So the therapist acts almost like a sociological consultant.
They teach the schizoid patient social mimicry.
Social mimicry.
Yeah, how to deploy appropriate eye contact,
when to nod,
how to utilize small talk as a tool to navigate the workplace
without drawing negative attention.
You weren't trying to make them crave the party,
you were just teaching them how to walk through the room
without bumping into the furniture.
Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
So we've covered distance caused
by a hypervigilant fear of harm
and distance caused by a profound neurological apathy.
Now we look at the third person at the party.
Right.
This profile pairs physical distance
with an entirely altered perception of reality.
This is schizotypal personality disorder.
And looking at the coding in the ICD manual,
there is a glaring structural anomaly here.
F21.
Exactly.
The first two we explored were F60.0 and F60.1.
They sit squarely in the F60 block,
which is dedicated to personality disorders.
But schizotypal is yanked out of that neighborhood entirely
and placed in the F21 block
right alongside the schizophrenia spectrum.
Yes, it is.
Why the different categorization?
I mean, what is mechanically happening
in this patient's mind that requires moving them
into a different clinical zip code?
Well, the placement reflects the presence
of cognitive and perceptual distortions
that you simply do not see
in the other personality disorders.
Like what?
Schizotypal features the severe social detachment
we saw in the schizoid profile,
but it introduces this mechanism of cognitive slippage.
Their brain's pattern recognition software
is hyperactive and totally dysregulated.
The sources refer to this as magical thinking
and ideas of reference.
Let's break down the mechanics of an idea of reference
because it's a really fascinating neurological glitch.
It really is.
An idea of reference occurs when the brain assigns
profound personalized salience to random neutral stimuli.
Okay.
Normally your brain filters out background noise, right?
You drive past a billboard for a local bank,
your brain categorizes it as irrelevant
and you forget it instantly.
Right, it's just noise.
But a schizotypal brain fails to filter that stimulus.
Instead, it flags the billboard as highly significant,
leading the individual to believe
the specific wording on the sign
is a hidden message directed entirely at them.
Wow.
Yeah, perhaps instructing them
on like a spiritual path for the day.
So it's a deeply personalized mystical connection
to just random environmental noise.
The literature also notes they hold odd beliefs,
have unusual processual experiences
like feeling a strange energy
or a presence in an empty room.
And their speech patterns can be highly eccentric,
relying on these loose associations or metaphors
that only they really understand.
And because their internal processing of reality
is so fundamentally different from the baseline,
interacting with the general public creates immense friction.
Which explains the isolation.
Right.
The social distance they maintain
is often a byproduct of this friction.
They realize others do not see the world the way they do,
which generates social anxiety
that does not diminish with familiarity.
This raises an important question
for clinicians navigating the dual diagnostic traps here.
Because schizotypal is walking a very thin tightrope.
On one side, you have schizoid personality disorder
because both feature severe social detachment.
Right, but the eccentricity is the dividing line there.
The schizoid person is detached and flat, right?
They aren't experiencing magical thinking
or perceptual oddities.
They are just solitary.
Schizotypal adds that distorted mystical layer.
And on the other side of the tightrope,
you have actual schizophrenia.
Schizotypal is sitting right there
in the F21 schizophrenia spectrum block.
So mechanically, how is it not just a case of schizophrenia?
It comes down to intensity, duration,
and the preservation of reality testing.
Schizotypal is clinically described as attenuated.
Attenuated, okay.
Yeah, meaning the symptoms are dialed down.
The patient might feel a strange presence
or believe they possess a sixth sense,
but they are not experiencing sustained unmistakable
hallucinations.
So no auditory hallucinations telling them what to do.
Exactly.
They don't hear a distinct external voice
commanding them to act,
and they do not suffer the catastrophic breakdown
of cognitive function seen in acute schizophrenia.
They touch the border of psychosis,
but they don't cross over and live there.
Which explains the shift in the treatment protocol.
Psychotherapy for schizotypal focuses
on reality testing and social skills training.
But because we're dealing with cognitive slippage
and dopamine dysregulation,
the pharmacological approach changes.
The sources indicate that treatment
frequently includes low dose antipsychotic medications.
It does, yeah.
Mechanically, what is that medication
doing to a schizotypal brain?
Well, antipsychotics, even at low doses,
work by blocking dopamine receptors,
specifically in the mesolimbic pathway of the brain.
Okay.
Dopamine is heavily involved in how the brain
assigns salience or importance to things.
By dialing down the dopamine transmission,
the medication reduces the volume of the background noise.
It stops the brain from flagging that random billboard
as a profound personal message.
That makes total sense.
Yeah, it quiets the perceptual oddities
just enough that the patient can actually engage
with the psychotherapy.
So what does this all mean?
If you're listening to this
and you're trying to mentally organize
this deep dive into cluster A,
let's establish the definitive golden rule.
Okay.
What is the overarching law
that governs all three of these profiles?
Paranoid, schizoid, and schizotypal
and separates them from the heavier psychotic disorders.
The overarching rule is the maintenance of reality testing.
That is the hard boundary in the diagnostic sand.
Reality testing.
Yes.
These are personality disorders,
or in the case of schizotypal,
an attenuated spectrum disorder.
They represent deeply ingrained,
lifelong patterns of perceiving, relating, and coping.
Right.
The psychological lens through which they view the world
might be cracked by fear,
it might be heavily tinted by apathy,
or it might fundamentally distort the light
through magical thinking.
But the eye behind the lens
is still anchored in shared reality.
That's a great metaphor.
None of these three profiles involve
a total fixed break from reality
or the presence of frank, unmistatable psychosis.
They interact with the world from a profound distance,
but they're still in the same world.
Let's bring it all back to where we started.
We are back at the crowded party
we've taken the deep dive into the clinical mechanics,
and now we understand the hidden architecture of the room.
You have three people standing alone.
Yeah.
The paranoid person is standing alone
because their hypervigilant nervous system
is actively scanning the crowd for threats,
terrified that engagement equals exploitation.
The schizoid person is standing alone.
Because their neurobiology simply lacks
the reward circuitry for social interaction,
they have absolutely zero appetite for the noise.
Exactly.
And the schizotypal person is standing alone
because their brain is assigning magical salience
to random environmental stimuli,
making the regular party chatter
feel overwhelmingly alien to them.
Three identical physical behaviors,
three entirely different psychological universes.
It really makes you wonder
as we look at the trajectory of modern culture.
What do you mean?
Well, as our society moves increasingly online
where asynchronous distant communication is the norm,
where you can work, shop, and exist
without ever sharing physical space
or making eye contact with another human,
are we unintentionally building a world
perfectly designed to accommodate cluster A?
Oh, wow.
And if the environment shifts to perfectly fit the isolation,
does the clinical disorder eventually disappear
into the new baseline of normal?
That is a phenomenal question to leave you with.
If a society no longer demands the party,
do we stop pathologizing the people
who never wanted to attend in the first place?
Next time you see someone standing on the fringes
quietly watching the room,
maybe don't assume you know the mechanics
of why they're standing there.
Thanks for joining us on this deep dive.
We'll see you next time.